just alfonso ribeiro may have cha-cha
for the last time hey guys I'm Sara
Flanagan and here's what's trending on
ET now
the Dancing with the Stars fan favorite
injured his back during rehearsals
Wednesday now rumors are swirling that
he might have to pull out of the
competition a rep for Dancing with the
Stars tells ET that Alfonso is currently
under medical evaluation and it's still
being determined if he'll compete in
Monday's semifinals this is just the
latest in a series of injuries for
Alfonso the former fresh print star told
us about a few others Miami heron you
limped up on the stage yes going on
Explorer Ellis what's going on well we
both have a lot of injuries um I I hurt
my toe my big toe I jammed it like week
two and then when I actually did the
Carlton on the show I injured my groin
Oh anybody who would know Wow Bruins
take a long time to heal yes recio's
really the only answer and don't go we
don't have it yeah and and then Whitney
hurt her back because we were doing a
trick at dress rehearsal and she flipped
and I my foot went right out from
underneath me we both went down in the
middle of the trick and hey it was very
scary
yeah well soon elfonzo we hope to see
you on dancing Monday night on ABC stick
with ET online for the latest on his
injury bye guys
you